that whenever you know what happened
when I try to commit suicide I felt like
I was truly alone in this world I said
you know what
and I told and I didn't explain this to
Ben so many times and then it was a
struggle for him he's my partner yeah
and I had to let him know I feel this
way where I think I will be happier if I
wasn't on this world and he explained to
me he goes do you realize how many
people need you in your life and I can't
I couldn't I couldn't her to grasp okay
I couldn't I couldn't accept it I said
no and and it was just so much where I
end up trying to do it and thank God I
did it wrong yes dad you know to say it
in such a like cynical way I'm glad I
did it wrong because I went I persevered
through it um you know when I was
talking to you about your uh you know
she so she so cat messaged me on
Instagram and I actually met her how did
I meet you I taught a show right yeah
well it's a couple shows and I met you
right and it's it's weird how sometimes
when you're going through a lot of dark
things you you just you focus on
everything that's wrong it's very easy
to get sucked into that ship and what I
was telling her was when she was she you
know just to be frank and honest and
she's okay with this too is that she
attempted to kill herself like it wasn't
like some foolhardy attempt she actually
tried to kill herself and it didn't work
out you know and from my perspective
from what you were telling me that you
were going through and for somebody who
admires you right yeah you're a fan but
you're somebody that I admire as well
it's very easy to look at your cup half
empty remember I told you that yeah
right cuz but if I told you what I saw
from the outside it was something that
you were doing that was so admirable but
when you're in this dark space it's so
hard to be your own beacon of life yeah
and you know what and you know what it
was really messed up about it was when I
went to a couple of people that I'm
close with I told them that I was going
through the depression and you know what
they said to me they said what do you
have to be depressed about if you have a
house you have dogs you have a man
and that doesn't you don't have to worry
about cheating on you because they know
our relationship they're like you have
money you have a career and I go well
thanks I gave me it opened up my eyes to
know who the [ __ ] my real friends are
because they literally asked me that
what do you have to be sad about yeah
then that's such a terrible way to look
at it because I feel like sometimes
people they diminish what somebody's
going through at the moment everybody
has these moments where they feel
defeated right and I think like having
that strong support group was great when
you came to me I didn't know what to say
actually yeah I didn't know what to say
the only thing that I could do at the
moment was to tell you like how how you
how I see your cup is full you know and
I didn't want to tell you to like you're
ungrateful that's not that wasn't the
message I was giving you you know what I
wanted to say was like take a step back
and look at how great you're doing like
you're doing you fought cancer twice
that was an opportunity that most people
would kill for you know and the fact
that you survived that [ __ ] and then on
top of that from your cancer I mean I
know this is like maybe me trying to
make a positive spin on things but you
found your passion because of this
cancer yeah yeah you didn't go through
this [ __ ] you would be still working at
a hospital yeah it's so funny you bring
that up because my fiance's friend
Jessica that was his coworker before I
end up going because I told you I'm such
a hard worker and I'm always trying to
work yeah before I end up going to chemo
I actually posted on my facebook
Instagram like hey anyone want to place
any orders I'm going for chemo on
Saturday place to order see how yeah and
she was like Ben what the [ __ ] is wrong
with her like this [ __ ] is wrong like
why is she trying to work that's the
thing you know like I like I said like
you're it's for me in your perspective
if you could think about it your cup is
really full yeah you know like I'm not
telling you that that in the sense of
like oh look at her she's not grateful
for what she has I'm saying that if you
take a step back from your situation and
mind you you have been through a lot
your father when your father was in
prison for 12 years of your life you
don't have that strong father figure you
want the [ __ ] chemotherapy twice
after you already be cancer
but how I see it is it's like this woman
who has been through all this [ __ ] she's
already coming out on top a lot of
people don't have that you know and I
think like for you it's it's very easy
to go into that dark space and I'll be
real with you like I don't know if I'd
be any stronger than you are I don't
know that I don't I don't know it's very
easy to get into that dark space it is
and especially for me when I actually do
everything alone like with my work I'm
home alone I answer inquiries alone I
look at but I do bookings everything
about about my life is home base all the
time alone and when I own my when bin
comes home it's like two three hours and
then we're back at it the next day you
know so I think at them at the time
there were a lot of outlets where we
came up with solutions that's another
thing is that he said you know what I
think that what you're lacking is is a
human interaction yeah because he was
like you know you do see your customers
you know everyday you see your customers
but he's like babe you don't have you
know human interaction anymore and he's
like the happiest I ever saw you was
when you were working at the hospital
yeah and I actually worked at the the
cancer floor of the hospital too so it
was great for me because I could relate
to them and I did really great on that
floor but I'd have to agree that I think
that it was the years adding up to being
alone all the time and then still
struggling with and it's even though
it's a little person it doesn't matter I
went with like four years after the
whole cancer thing not having a normal
menstrual cycle yeah so it was like it's
like what is my body doing this why am i
doing this am I gonna like there's all
these questions are going through my
head every day still to this day am I
gonna get struck with cancer again you
know am I gonna be able to have a kid am
I going to ever become a mother am I
gonna do this
is do I even love baking you know do I
just love baking for the satisfaction of
making people happy because it doesn't
bring me much joy anymore but I love
making people my goal like
my my thing is I love to make people
happy I loved I loved taking care of
people and I feel like sometimes you put
I put myself on that back burner
because I was always taking care of
everyone else you know that's that's the
hard part right like I I think I really
appreciate people who live a life of
servitude and I think like Christianity
has a lot of that [ __ ] into it yeah
thoughts isn't christianity brought the
protestant religion where you live for
others versus yourself i am there's a
downside to that because when you start
living for others instead of yourself
there's there's moments when you are by
yourself
and you're not getting that reciprocated
appreciation you feel really alone yeah
and it's hard even with your friendships
right you're like oh [ __ ] I didn't think
that these people have my back like I
thought that yeah I'm telling I'm
telling you you would be surprised like
like I said I lost to my closest like I
said I started friendships here after I
moved here from Hurricane Katrina but
all the friends that I got here right
when I moved to California they've
stayed my friends so 10 plus years all
my closest friends under 10 people have
stayed my friends but I lost two of my
great friends because of it because I
said not when I explained to them what
was going on I actually told them that I
tried to commit suicide yeah and they
say that's what they said to me was why
they said you're stupid you have a you
know you have everything we don't think
that you have any reason to do that and
I go you know what I understand but I at
the time I just need to reach out to you
yeah and that's and that's what I did
for you is that I feel like because I've
been in and I try to tell people I'm
like I've been watching someone who I
look up to and yeah that has given great
advice I wanted to get advice and I was
like by the same time I had also had
another friend who told me I can't give
you advice because I ain't never been
through this and I understood her I said
if you haven't been through it then I
can't expect advice and there's a lot of
people who you it's it's great it's
actually a great thing that you don't
have a good big circle friends who word
are depressed you know if it's a good
thing
say exactly my friends aren't depressed
but it's harder especially but yeah like
I said the person that definitely helped
me through this was definitely been my
family and a couple of my great friends
that it just brought us closer and it
again it's it's it's hard it's you know
hard to talk about you know I don't
really know your friends that you lost
but you know sometimes people just don't
know how to give advice and some people
just don't know how to listen because a
lot of the times what happens is it up
guilty of this too is that we when we
give advice we put too much of ourselves
into it and we lack that empathy when
somebody's hurting right because what
they see is what happens is when
somebody talks down to somebody when
they're going through think going
through something they go you have
nothing to worry about
right look at what I'm going through and
I'm not complaining about this [ __ ] so
they put they put themselves in a
position that you're in without being
empathetic and without reaching out you
know and what happens that is that you
minimize how somebody feels right yeah
some people take that to the stream
we're like where they're not really
minimizing how they feel and they get
exaggerated with their [ __ ] but in times
like this I think that it's hard for
people to understand when it's when you
need to listen and when you need to give
advice yeah because listening is a lot
of the times is what people just need
they don't you can't say you can't solve
other people's problems sometimes yeah
they don't want an answer back they
don't want to answer they just want a
literally an ear to listen to yeah just
be there for me and support me right
because even when you contact me like I
don't know you want that close of a
personal level a lot of the stuff I'm
just finding out right now mm-hm
right but in that moment I'm just like
okay for somebody to reach out to me who
doesn't know me very well she must be
going through some real [ __ ] right for
me I met you and you know you're a very
positive human being and you're really
great to be around so I'm like there
must be something that she's really
going through them when you told me you
you actually tried to kill yourself and
I'm like what is this girl going through
right now that her perspective is
slipped because how I see her is
completely different from how she sees
herself